did was there anything in hell week that
like tripped you up or were you just
like hell yeah the reason I say hell
yeah for me is because I like sucked at
everything well I didn't suck I was I
was okay at everything but I had to put
out really hard to pass runs I had to
put out really hard to pass the old car
so I had to put out really hard to pass
the swims and look everyone's putting
out yeah but I had to put put out really
hard to pass the evolutions but in hell
week it wasn't it's not pass fail it's
just keep going we do there's anything
I'm okay at it's like oh I can keep
going right I will keep going and so for
me hell week was almost like a break
because you just had to keep going which
I was good at everything else like I did
I failed I failed to Four Mile time run
I I paced myself I was an idiot I mean I
wasn't fast enough to Pace I just needed
to Sprint I failed to swim and again
like a bunch of people failed to swim
and I was one of them so that sucked I
don't know if I failed in an obstacle
course I probably did